It all started in 1983 with reports of human
trafficking in the heart of Sin City.
The FBI had gotten word of a potential trafficking
ring operating out of an abandoned department
store in Las Vegas, Nevada, and immediately
began organizing a secret raid on the building.
While they would indeed encounter something
horrifying within that abandoned department
store, it wasn’t criminals or human trafficking.
In fact, it wasn’t human at all.
This is the horrifying story of SCP - 847.
After weeks of planning, the raid on the department
store was conducted in the dead of night.
Agents covered all the exits and entrances
and a helicopter was stationed nearby in case
anyone attempted to run.
It should have been a perfect trap.
But things never go as planned when you don’t
know what you’re dealing with.
The agents breached the door, and began searching
the darkened building.
It didn’t appear that there was any power,
so the traffickers must have had great night
vision and a high tolerance for creepy locales.
Agents soon heard a faint humming sound coming
from below - a generator.
It must be located in the basement and be
the hub of this criminal enterprise.
Readying themselves for whatever they were
about to find, the agents descended into the
basement.
As they moved deeper into the building, they
found that lighting rigs had been set up - they
must be getting closer to something, but that
“something” was still a mystery.
A senior FBI Special Agent was leading the
charge, his pistol drawn and ready.
It was quiet.
Too quiet.
Did the traffickers already realize they were
coming and clear out?
He was ready to consider this bust a bust
when he heard a quiet mewling in the distance.
A persistent, whining whimper that was undeniably
human.
He gave the signal to his fellow agents to
follow the noise.
They proceeded forward towards the pained
sounds and found themselves in a wide, well-lit
room filled with department store mannequins.
All were broken to some degree - some were
totally smashed to pieces, some were chained
to walls and locked in cages, others were
wrapped in plastic.
The agent wondered whether this was some kind
of twisted joke, or a messed up avant garde
art piece.
That’s when he noticed Her: A single, crouched
figure in the distance, hunched over and whimpering
in a darkened corner of the room near a full-length
mirror.
He couldn’t fully make her out, but he got
the sense that something was wrong - she was
injured, bent over.
Was she even missing an arm?
Just what had these monsters done to this
woman?
He whispered a request for back up into his
radio, and pushed on.
When they got within 50 meters of the strange
woman, her demeanor changed entirely.
She jerked around - her movements forced,
erratic, and painful-looking.
The woman stared directly into the agent’s
eyes and began hobbling towards him., occasionally
stopping to strike a pose as if modelling
during a photo shoot.
Just then the agent made a horrifying realization
- this thing moving towards them wasn’t
a woman at all, it was a living mannequin.
As she got closer though, he also realized
that the mannequin’s broken left forearm
had been carved into a large shiv.
A female junior FBI agent had been one of
the many to pour into the room when the raid
leader had radioed for backup.
The second she entered the fifty meter range
of this strange mannequin, everything changed.
In an instant, its eyes and mouth began dripping
with a thick, viscous resin.
Its whimpering gasps suddenly became vicious,
earsplitting screeches, and it turned its
gaze from the senior FBI agent.
It was now focused on the junior agent who
had just entered the room and broke into a
terrifying run straight towards her.
The mannequin moved with a violent, single-minded
purpose.
Other agents began firing but it was running
freakishly fast and easily dodged most of
the bullets.
The few that actually hit seemed to do nothing
to slow the creature down.
It shrugged off the damage and kept running.
With a great leap, it landed on the terrified
junior agent, and began jabbing at her with
its bladed arm.
The other agents stopped firing, fearing they
might accidentally hit their colleague during
the panic.
The mannequin was ruthless, clawing and stabbing,
with the strange resin leaking out of its
every orifice.
Terrified and unable to reach her gun, the
agent remembered her training - she reached
into her belt and grabbed her stun gun, jamming
the two probes up against the creature’s
chest and giving it 30,000 volts.
The creature spasmed, fell backwards, and
collapsed in a heap on the ground - frozen.
This was the first recorded encounter with
SCP - 847 - a violent living mannequin with
a serious problem with women.
This terrifying report was passed up the chain
of command until it landed on the desk of
a Foundation Agent working in the FBI.
The Foundation quickly swooped in and claimed
the mannequin, delivered necessary amnestic
treatment to all who’d witnessed it, and
closely observed the female junior FBI agent’s
recovery in a private hospital with Foundation
ties.
As it turns out, they were right to do so,
as the junior agent was in for a gruesome
fate.
While the wounds she’d suffered at the hands
of SCP - 847 didn’t appear fatal, the fact
that the mannequin’s anomalous resin excretions
entered the open wound changed everything.
Several hours after being committed, the junior
agent began complaining of limb stiffness
and difficulty moving.
This quickly developed into full paralysis.
Over time, her skin and internal organs began
to harden, until the process - dubbed plastination
- came to a gruesome end.
The junior agent wasn’t just dead, she had
been transformed into a mannequin.
Foundation researchers were met with a truly
horrifying realization - This meant that all
the other broken mannequins found with SCP
- 847 were likely once living humans, attacked
and transformed by the anomaly, now a source
for new harvested body parts.
Now safely interred at a Foundation containment
facility though, the real tests on SCP - 847
to determine its behavior and physical attributes
could begin.
The most important detail about SCP - 847
is that its aggression is exclusively directed
towards women, as opposed to when it encounters
men and its instincts are more self-destructive.
Through a series of tests and observations,
researchers have been able to pin down three
different distinct patterns of behavior for
SCP - 847.
Pattern Z behaviors occur when there are no
humans standing within fifty meters of SCP
- 847.
The mannequin will seek out a full length
mirror, and pose in front of it, much like
a department store mannequin attempting to
show off its clothes.
It remains largely inanimate during these
periods, and will very occasionally use a
finger - or whatever appendage is available,
given its habit for self-mutilation - to scratch
messages on nearby surfaces.
Pattern Y behaviors occur when male humans
with XY chromosomes enter a fifty meter radius
around SCP - 847.
Just like its reaction to the male FBI agents
who found it, 847 will initially emit vocalizations
that seem like whimpering gasps, before making
eye contact and striking provocative poses
while approaching the subject.
It will then remain static, and allow the
male subject to pose its body.
However, after the male subject leaves the
area, 847 will enter a state of considerable
distress, and begin removing or shattering
parts of its body.
The Foundation has found that the parts removed
or shattered are often consistent with parts
that the male subjects found displeasing during
interactions, showing a masochistic desire
to impress.
These parts are then harvested back from plastinated
victims.
Which brings us to the most dangerous of its
behavior patterns.
Pattern X behaviors occur when female humans
enter a 50 meter radius around the creature.
847 will immediately become brutally aggressive,
switching its noises from whimpers to violent
screeches and growls.
847 also experiences enhanced physical capabilities
during Pattern X states - its speed has been
measured at 45 kilometers per hour, making
it as fast as the legendary SCP - 096.
It’s also been shown to exhibit extreme
physical strength.
It’s during this pattern of behavior that
it begins excreting its deadly resin, which
has been proven to only be dangerous to women.
In these states, the only thing capable of
reliably pacifying the being is a powerful
electric shock.
The shock causes the creature’s resin to
harden, temporarily incapacitating it for
roughly five minutes.
Other conventional weapons and damage has
no meaningful effect on SCP - 847.
After a number of incidents that had sad and
violent endings, the Foundation Ethics Committee
forbade the use of female D-Class personnel
in SCP - 847 testing.
When it came to female subjects, 847 always
slipped into a state of extreme aggression,
so instead the Foundation began testing with
male subjects in hopes of better understanding
the dynamics between human males and SCP-847.
Various misogynistic D-Class males were introduced
into the containment chamber, which was modelled
to look like a bedroom for the purposes of
behavioral study.
Each one, either during or after their interaction
with SCP - 847, was told to comment on some
aspect they felt dissatisfied with.
The mannequin shattered its own chest after
hearing it described as being out of proportion.
After another D-Class called its nose ugly,
the mannequin broke it off.
After another said that its hair was out of
fashion and commented on its inability to
drink, it tore out its hair and liver.
All parts were replaced after the experiments.
Things took their most violent and upsetting
turn yet with the introduction of D-7294.
A lot of the time, D-Class personnel are considered
to be as anonymous as they are expendable.
But D-7294 is an exception.
Before becoming D-Class, he was a successful
cello teacher who brutally murdered one of
his teenage students and her mother.
He’s typically employed in tests when the
Foundation wishes to see interactions between
anomalies and humans with confirmed psychopathic
personalities.
During his interaction with SCP - 847, he
belittled and humiliated the mannequin.
He forced it into uncomfortable poses, and
even snapped off one of its fingers before
being dragged from the room by Foundation
guards.
In the following debrief, he further berated
the mannequin as “useless” and “lousy”
at its job of being controlled by him.
In response, 847 extracted its own brains,
eyes, and clavicle before shattering its own
hands in dismay.
So why does SCP - 847 behave this way?
While it may appear monstrous, it seems that
the reason SCP - 847 does what it does is
all too human: It hurts women because it itself
is hurting, and it’s willing to hurt itself
even more for the approval of the objects
of its desire.
As a result, it’s an anomaly trapped in
an endless cycle of pain and violence.
Perhaps one day it’ll be able to free itself
from the loop, but that day is unlikely to
come for this murderous mannequin anytime
soon.
Now go check out “SCP - 035 - The Possessive
Mask” and “SCP - 2935 - O, Death” for
more chilling stories from the SCP Foundation!